what does a typical day of a consultant
at mckinsey bcg or bane look like caveat
of course every project is different but
this should give you a good idea at 8 30
in the morning you might meet with your
team in the team room to go over a
check-in together with the project lead
everyone will discuss his or her
priorities for the day at 9 00 am you
might have a meeting with a client from
the finance team to go over some numbers
that the person sent to you and ask some
terrifying questions on the data you
received at 10 you might sit together
with a line manager from the client to
get additional input for your analysis
then you might have two hours for
yourself in the team room to get some
work done at midday you go to the
canteen of your client together with
some colleagues to grab some lunch
afterwards one of your partners one of
the senior leaders of your firm might
fly in and meet you for one or two hours
of problem-solving session then around 6
pm you might do a team checkout where
everyone shares the progress of the day
and also discusses what they still have
on their plate for the remainder of the
evening around 7pm you might drive to
the hotel 14 dinner when everyone goes
to the hotel room to wrap up the day if
you would be able to close your laptop
at 10 pm that wouldn't be too bad follow
for more korean sites